passé un événement qui nous a tous
marqués la saison à venir on se
souvenait pas non le bug technique
ah oui alors vous devez vous demander
tout ce qui s'est passé
les téléspectateurs se demande ce qui a
bien pu se passer à ce que je dirai que
l'émission a démarré avec 45 minutes de
retard y avait plus de lumière plus de
son plus d'image mais il y avait un
meilleur audience
ouais j'ai vu parce que forcément on
voit les audiences médiamétrie de matin
et marquer incident technique et je vois
incident technique
4.3 25 grenoble cartonné j'ai dit à la
chaîne on peut pas faire un probable
s'appelle alors oui mais alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ici sur plateau mais oui
j'avais une bonne techniquement été
spectateur se demande est bien
l'indiquent vous a ramené tout ce qui
s'est passé
ah non minute par leur numéro ça c'est
pour me regarde je peux pas démarré
parce que j'avais l'image non plus donc
le son il aurait démarré c'est pour ça
qu'il est marpa et la régie mais le truc
et essaie d'être connecté toi c'est leur
priorité
voix isabelle avait 22 ans et à justin
chante et renée sait et on le dit on dit
luc cynober sont habillés d'un problème
avec un s pour ça commence bien
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qui les races ras le bonbon
même le bordeaux on dirait qu'on est
frais regret qu'on est sur antenne 2
81-11 va enfin mettre un best-of de
barnaby ça va on a un problème
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on fait là ça gagne rien de
sa carrière grâce à rien si on fait
mieux pour l'instant je vous explique on
peut juste faire ça avec une caméra
portable c'est à dire hier un cadreur et
moi j'ai un micro pour tout le monde
et je vais prendre un moucheron j'aime
le foot bien sûr à grand chose la marge
on est enfin on dirait c'est bon tout
est réparé pour le moment ça peut sauter
tout en affichant rappellera sans qui
cette chaude elle exceptionnelle et j'ai
trouvé gentil moi la vie n'avait plus
dire qu'il a il a donné ce genre de
problème oui exact toujours
compréhensifs du tout du genre à
chercher des responsables n'ont pas dû
dans la chair versa non parce que je
suis tombé sur un truc
enfin regardez pas moins pas moi je
pense pas et bien ce jeu des noms quatre
feux des noms cac à vous je vous dévoile
ensuite des noms cohen a manqué mon père
venait où il veut des noms les rivaux
les responsables trouvera vont tout
perdre trouvera les responsables sur mon
père trouvera les réponses aux pères
trouvera les responsables